order order welcome to the first
evidence session of the culture media
and Sport committee's pre-legitative
scrutiny of the government draft Media
bill we're joined today by the
commercial Public Service broadcasters
we have Magnus Brooke the group director
of strategy policy and regulation from
ITV uh Khalid Hyatt the director of
strategy from Channel 4 and Mitchell
Simmons the vice president for public
policy and government Affairs at
Paramount which includes channel five
before we begin it might be very helpful
for the panel and those watching our
proceedings to be clear that today's
session is not about the widely reported
issues at this morning and ITV and the
broader implications for public service
broadcasting we will be hearing next
week from Dame Carolyn McCall itv's CEO
specifically to discuss those matters
and we'll be raising them of course with
other broadcasters in due course as well
today we very much want to focus on the
draft media well and this significant
implications that that has for the
industry before we begin questioning can
I just ask members if they have any
interest to declare please Simon I'm a
former employee of ITV
uh John
yes I'm a former
um news presenter at ITV
I used to work for ITN which was part of
ITV specifically on channel 4 news so I
cover both of those and I I've accepted
Hospitality from Channel 4 in the past
two years
I have worked for ITV
anyone else no
thank you very much
uh
so I'm going to kick off the questions
and I want to start by talking about the
public service remit we know that the
current legislation uh
has a requirement to provide specific
coverage on various genres including
things like education and drama and
comedy and children's and religion but
those uh specifications are removed by
this new piece of legislation what will
be the consequences of removing the
specific genres from the public service
broadcasting remit Magnus
um I'm not sure there necessarily will
be uh very significant implications from
that partly because uh what that does is
look at the system as a whole it doesn't
look at any individual broadcaster and
say you have to provide each of those
genres as part of your contribution to
PSB so in itv's case a core part of our
contribution is news whether that's
Nations uh Regional national news also
current affairs production outside
London independent production so we make
a very significant contribution to PSB
in those areas but no individual PSB
with a possible exception of the BBC can
cover every single area of the PSB
Waterfront and I think what that looks
at is the system taken as a whole is it
is it providing appropriate coverage of
all of those genres so I don't think in
our case at least it's going to make an
enormous difference to to how we deliver
PSB because I think we're very clear
what our unique contribution is as part
of an overall system and of course the
secretary of state is is proposing to
take a power to impose that new quota
case and should that be necessary should
there be a concern from ofcom in
particular that there's a particular
genre of programming where there's a
shortfall of delivery but it worked
seven Channel fours thoughts similar
position so we very much support the
approach to more in a more
outcomes-based approach to regulation of
PSP and therefore support the the
approach the PSP remit that's been
defined in the draft Media bill at the
same time we as Channel 4 will also
retain our own specific and distinctive
PSP remit to the challenge to provide
Innovative content and therefore we'll
continue to fulfill that remit and we
measure ourselves on delivery of that
remit through the statement of media
content policy which we publish in ofcom
reviews and holds us to account to but
at the same time of course there will
continue to be obligations in the
license for Channel 4 and for other
broadcasters on news current affairs
Regional Productions independent
Productions which will fit with the key
areas of content that the government has
specified in the draft Media bill and
again we'll make positive contribution
to PSB in the round
Mitchell what kind of reassurances can
you give us that taken together Public
Service broadcasters will continue to be
able to provide a diversity in the range
of programs in such things as arts and
religion I think the key point to me on
the two previous answers there's the the
PSB ecology is built around a certain
level of complementarity between the
different broadcasters so we have
increased obligations on children's
content which have the milkshake program
each morning we have UH responsibilities
on current affairs Regional programming
news that is different from the
obligations on other Public Service
broadcasters and the idea is it taken as
a whole the obligations on each of the
broadcasters create some diversity and
complementarity between the broadcasters
I think we all
um you know we never called for a
simplification of the remit I think
we're very happy with the simplification
of the remit and we don't foresee from
ourselves as channel five any change in
the output that we will
um we'll put on our schedule as a result
of these changes
do you think
[Music]
you think decline in the way that these
different aspects are covered in the
linear services and attemptation to put
everything onto the on-demand well I
think that's going to be an important
safeguard for off-corn when it's looking
at this issue clearly a key element of
the draft Media bill is about
recognizing that as audiences are moving
away from live TV a linear TV viewing
and are starting to view online that
PSPs will be able to meet some of their
obligations through their online
services but equally it's important that
viewers who are still
watching on linear for primarily on the
linear channels are also able to access
that PSP content so I think
as we as we manage that move away from
linear towards VOD and it's going to
happen over a period of time we need to
make sure that the bill is pretty good
we feel it in the round ensures that
ofcom has the duties to ensure just as
colored is remarked that if there is a
gap if there is an issue in conjunction
with the secretary of state they're able
to make an intervention to correct
things if they think they're not happy
College we're concerned that those who
aren't digitally enabled those who don't
have access to the internet for you know
a whole range of reasons won't be
excluded from the range of different uh
types of programming what reassurances
can you give us that there won't be that
any sort of decline in the public
service provision on your main linear
Channel yeah so we're committed to our
main linear channel the the the course
channel for service which is you know
the designated public service
broadcaster but we deliver our remit
across all our services of course but
we're committed to the core linear
service and you know whilst at the same
time time transforming our business in
order to drive digital growth to
anticipate and reshape what we're doing
you know in response to the to the
market change and changing View and
behavior that Mitchell is described but
you know I think it's worth just being
clear that you know we as we as Channel
foreigners did all the broadcasters have
very much supported the extension of the
licenses for the digital terrestrial
multiplexes so we're all committed to
and want a linear terrestrial digital
broadcasting to continue well into the
2030s so that's absolutely cool to what
we're doing you know we're talking to
ofcom right now about the renewal of our
broadcasting license which expires at
the end of 2024 and again that will
continue to include obligations on the
linear Channel
um but at the same time given for
Channel 4 given that we do have a skew
younger than other Public Service
broadcasters we are of course
anticipating what a younger audience is
doing where are they watching content
how can we deliver our remit across
streaming platforms more you know more
effectively and try growth in that area
and similarly expanding onto social
platforms platforms through full Studio
and Magnus but what about for ITV we
know that you've had an enormous amount
of investment in your online health
services and
um
viewing on demand services in the last
couple of years and at the same time
cuts to some other aspects such as
children's TV how will we protect the
linear services at ITV and I think I can
reassure you on that in the sense that
what we're what I think we're moving to
is a hybrid world of linear and
on-demand with streaming effectively a
sort of hybrid of hybrids in a way it's
a delivery of a linear broadcast service
but not linear service through IP but
for us we've never really made Niche
content Niche PSB content we've made
content for which we want trying to find
a mass audience so we're trying to find
that that spot where we can get a big
audience for PSP content that's that's
our rationale as a PSB and the truth is
that we're going to have to serve the
linear audience and the on-demand
audiences equally over time because half
the audience or more than half the
audience is currently linear and and
there's a significant audience in on
demand if we're going to be able to pay
for the content we're going to have to
use it both on linear and on on demand
for some time to come at the moment I
think they're about 3.8 million
households that are IP only so they
don't have a broadcast feed coming in
there are some estimates that suggest
that might be up to 50 by 2030
um and we we anticipate that maybe 50 50
uh viewing in the in the UK television
market as a whole around 50 of viewing
will be on demand 50 Linear by about the
mid-2030s so for us to make to act to be
able to afford to pay for the content
we're going to have to as it were
advertised to an audience if you like on
linear because there's a very
significant audience there but there's a
very significant growing audience in on
demand so for us the idea that we just
put content in one place or the other
doesn't make any commercial sense
you very much Simon thank you chair uh
good morning if we can talk about the
shift from proportion based quote just
absolute ones to start with if that's
all right how will that change the way
you fulfill your public service remit
Mitchell I'll come to you first if
that's all right um thank you I mean I
think from so the first one you speak of
Max's earlier comment Channel 5 still
has quite a significant linear audience
um channel five is uh destination for
factual television for
um leading on social issues for the
early broadcast of news at 5 PM so it
tends to have
um it tends to skew outside of the
Metropolitan centers outside of outside
of London and as a consequence we have
quite a strong
um linear viewing in terms of
um remit delivery
um we we therefore don't feel um I mean
we therefore don't we don't foresee a
significant significant change we feel
that
um what we provide brings audiences to
our to our schedule it's absolutely
critical that
um you know we do a full day of
programming and people arrive and we
provide some complementarity to the rest
of the um to the market but at the same
time my five is growing and we're also
um ensuring that audiences as they
gradually move there we're providing for
all of them so we don't foresee any
significant change to our output based
on that Khalid you know your audience is
very different to channel four because
you're more Metropolitan
um do you do you perceive a difference
an approach now in terms of application
so so I mean on the I mean on the on the
topical in the area of absolute quotas
you know we absolutely support the
principle that the government set out
that uh that that Public Service
delivery should count across the range
of platforms right and yeah and as we're
all say we're about balancing
um output on linear and streaming
services
um and you know we also support the
principal and welcome the principal that
any new absolute quotas will be no more
onerous than existing quotas but as
you've seen from our written evidence we
have expressed some concern about the
concept of absolute quotas and and the
reason for that is is is because of the
reduction in flexibility that those
absolute quotas would provide so with
the and and and and indeed we think the
effects of those twofold so one being
that that that by having absolute quotas
that reduces the incentive on
broadcasters to over deliver on quotas
when times are good because there's an
absolute number that you're trying to
hit and partly uh and partly reduce the
incentive to over deliver in order to
save up as it would in in order to
because it's because it's it's a there's
reduced flexibility to adjust
commissioning activity when times are
tougher uh you know and yeah and and so
and so so we do have some concerns about
the lack of flexibility that that those
that those absolute quotes would provide
and it's so it's an area that we have
been discussing with off common dcms in
order to in order to add in those
discussions uh so so
um that there is a there's I think the
government's position on that is is is
they they do want to implement the
absolute quota so I think we understand
that oftcom do share some of the
concerns about the lack of flexibility
uh but what but what what we get what we
don't have at this point is a is a
ready-made solution to how to address
those risks but it is but it's it's it's
a it's an area that we are alive to how
much of a risk is it to your business
well it's I mean all commercial
businesses we met you know we obviously
are facing into the ad Market we we make
we make commissioning decisions in order
to fulfill our remits and in and in the
light of the commercial circumstances
that we're facing and you know and
therefore reduce just reducing the
flexibility that we have available to us
does reduce some of the levers that we
have to pull uh and you know and and and
particularly in relation to for example
Regional production quotas uh for
instance you know where you know where
where where we're working with the
supplier base distributed across the
country you know absolute quotas create
a degree of compliance risk in in the
event that if you know if certain
programs are pushed out later and so on
and so forth there becomes a compliance
risk in relation to fulfillment of those
quizzes understood Magna same questions
here uh well look we we've slightly
different position on each channel four
which is I think we broadly support uh
volume bass quoted as one small
exception uh and and the reason for that
I think is that for us I mean as we've
talked about there are 3.8 million
households in the UK at the moment who
who don't have a broadcast service so
for them itvx is is effectively itv's
PSB contribution and that number is only
going to increase over time potentially
as much as 50 or so in the next 10 years
so for us it's important that we can
deliver our quotas uh online as well as
on linear
um and we think volume creators
delivered uh online are quite important
and the reason for that is a simple one
which is the denominator of a
percentage-based quota on an online
service is really really it is a
floating denominator effectively because
we've got 15 000 hours on itvx for
example at the moment that number
fluctuates rapidly over time over the
course of a year it's not like a 24 7
linear service where you have a
a fixed number of hours more or less and
therefore you can have a percentage
created relatively straightforwardly on
a service where you've got you've got a
big very big fluctuation potential or
significant fluctuation over time and
it's never constant it's never this
exactly the same amount of about so you
wouldn't actually know what the
percentage number was until you got to
the end of the year effectively if if
you're basing a percentage equator
around itvx which is why we would
support a volume-based quota as Khalid
said no no more and no less uh onerous
than let's say the average of What the
Creator would have been over the last
five years or so which I think is the
government's proposal the area where I
don't think we agree is in relation to
the or at least we have concerns is in
relation to the out of London spend
quota because they're the government's
proposed list is to actually write a
number down about this is the minimum
amount of money you have to spend
outside London and to khalid's point
about fluctuations in the advertising
Market if you take the covidia for
example uh you know would you be able to
net to guarantee that you could meet
absolute number of spend because in the
end our budget our budgets have to
fluctuate over time to reflect
fluctuations in the advertising Market
because we're commercially funded we do
have a concern that writing in a number
without any caveat around look it has to
be some reflection of economic
circumstance or or if you're outside a
certain set of tram lines then there may
be some flexibility around that number
that's all concern focusing on ITV eggs
for a second I know that you you
perceive that there's a problem with
keeping programs online for 30 days
could it explain and contextualize to to
us this morning why that's such a
problem for you yeah no very happy to
him the reason it matters is because it
links into the um prominence uh
obligation or the prominence benefit if
you like from the PSB point of view but
also as we may come on to talk about the
agreement objectives for the settlement
of disputes between PSPs and platforms
so that's why it matters
um because effectivity content has to be
up for 30 days on itvx in order to count
towards those two things
um and look from our point of view we
want to keep content as long as possible
because by definition that maximizes the
number of people who see it and
therefore maximizes the amount of money
we can make from advertising so that is
our Baseline position we want as much
content as for as many people as
possible as long as possible so that's
that's where we start there are in truth
rights reasons in a handful of areas
particularly news and particularly
daytime and the the specific issue there
is we rely the fair dealing exception in
relation to the use of music and images
and so on and our own legal view is it's
difficult for us to keep that content up
longer than seven days if we're relying
on those exceptions to maintain those
programs so it's specifically about news
and daytime as it happens actually not
that many people want to access news and
daytime programs after seven days in
fact a vanishingly small number of
people do
and and we also think that it's
important that particularly news
programs have have an ability to get
prominence on on platforms so it's for
that reason there is also a sport there
is also just in a case of some sports
rights we simply don't have the right to
keep it up for as long as 30 days we'd
love to keep it up for as long as
possible understood and and Khalid and
Mitchell do you do either of you have
the same issue or similar concerns as
ITV in relation to keeping content on
for for 30 days online on your
respective on-demand Services Mitchell
uh I mean I think we we sort of
sympathetic to the ITV position in the
main issue for us has historically been
around the sports rights issue that
sometimes simply cannot get the rights
obviously you know we like to keep
content on there as long as possible but
on certain instances is simply not
possible so yeah understand Khalid yeah
and again I understand the position and
and you know from our perspective you
know we want the wide array the full
array of Channel 4 content that we carry
on our linear and streaming services to
be subject to PSP prominence
thank you very much Rupa um yes Sports
Rights was just mentioned I wanted to
turn to listed events so I suppose
that's one where the your usual binging
streaming on a box set versus linear
real time doesn't work well people do
watch it linear realtor and in
particular these listed events where
they go to traditionally broadcasters
where 95 reach is there and it's offered
for free there are worries that this
draft bill doesn't protect that listed
events regime enough
um yeah with things like the FA Cup The
Wimbledon those kind of things so I just
wondered do you foresee any problems in
the fact that this bill doesn't include
digital rights at all
yes we do um so look
um uh listen that's very important for
the delivery of PSB uh they're one of
the really best examples in of the way
in which PSP can bring the whole nation
together so young and old uh people from
all over that the country come together
we had I think a peak audits of 27
million people watching uh the Euros in
2012. demand on the National Grid when
everyone's putting their well at the
same time quite
um and but interestingly within that
about seven and a half percent or so of
our viewing for the 2021 or 2020 it was
wasn't it well uh Euros was actually
streamed so it wasn't broadcast it was
actually streamed and that's quite a
significant percentage and look we've
got two concerns on the digital rights
the first is around uh streaming so
there is an exception that already
exists where if you're not on a
regulated DPG but you'll run a streaming
service and that's a lot of the
streaming services at the moment then
you are not covered by the list event
rules so in principle you could buy the
rights to a listed event and then charge
for people to access it we don't think
that loophole's been closed entirely by
the media bill in fact it hasn't been
closed by the media Bill nor will it be
closed entirely by the extension of of
the regulation of epg's because quite a
few of these streaming services not on
EPG so we think that's that in
particular because that's about live
rights it is a really really important
uh loophole that does need to be closed
in the existing regime and the
government's got a bit of a way but not
quite as far as it needs to go to close
that the second one I think is is our
other digital rights and to give you an
example of say something like clip
rights where you can imagine a situation
where someone could auction clip rights
which we currently get as part of our
overall live rights for coverage but you
can imagine someone separating them off
and saying here's a separate package of
clip rides and you can show clips almost
immediately after the coverage has been
broadcast and you can show every single
clip if you want and you could string
that together and it would look a bit
like on an online or a social media
platform it would look it wouldn't look
like live coverage but it would be quite
close and there that a it undermines the
value from the psbs and listed events
but secondly I think it fragments the
audience because potentially what you
get are categories of the audience
younger people potentially choosing to
watch on on a social media service are
run by YouTube or or by um Facebook
rather than watching PSP and we we offer
all of these things currently via our
own services and it would be a Pity I
think to split up that audience to allow
those rights to go to other people and
gradually I think the psbs would find
themselves in in a bit of an old world
of Simply live streaming rather than
bringing the whole audience together
with the whole event and being able to
create a real but National Buzz around
what we do which is what we do at the
moment
see you are on record aren't you
um criticizing this loophole that would
allow unregulated you don't think this
sufficiently deals over at all I don't
okay so how would you amend the bill to
well I think I think what you need to do
is extend the um the definition of those
people who are not PSPs as well because
at the moment there's a definition uh I
think of uh it's a Broadcasting Service
and internet program service the
definition of Internet program service
at the moment requires you to have an
on-demand service associated with the
streaming service and I think that's the
that's the NAB of the problem because if
it just said a streaming service rather
than the definition of Internet program
service didn't require you also to have
an on-demand service associated with it
I think that might do it and that's the
difficulty of the definition at the
moment on under their proposed amendment
of section 98. we're happy to write to
the committee with the with the detail
of that because it does it does get you
into the drafting of of how you would
close that Loop but we thought we
thought the government had closed it but
actually looking at the definition of
Internet program service if you are a
streaming service without an on-demand
service you wouldn't fall into that
category and therefore you wouldn't be
covered by the right
of the rain quite a lot of them wouldn't
have an on-demand service associated
with them
uh call it the commercial broadcasters
and online demand Services Association
so it's misguided to
um and it restricts competition to not
have
um
the judicial rights within this regime
do you agree well no I I Echo everything
and agree with everything Magnus has
said and I think just I guess in a way
just just thinking about the context of
the media bill as a whole and nothing
because it's with everything that all of
us are saying here is that look what
what we think is that the legislative
framework needs to keep up with viewer
Behavior you know and as Magnus has said
you know we've got we see over 50 of
viewing today is to live content in
about 10 years time that would be about
a third of all viewing and so and and if
the intent of the policy intends is that
there are certain sporting events that
are considered important enough that
they should be seen
um they should be available to all
audiences universally available free to
watch that's you know perhaps you
support that principle given the way
viewing behavior is changing it is only
right that that principle extends the
digital platforms as well as linear
platforms okay and same question would
you like to yeah I mean we
wholeheartedly agree it's channel five I
mean channel five has uh is the smallest
broadcaster PSP rather has not
um had any listed events for for a while
though we have carried highlights for
listed events so um where the the main
uh listed event has been on a commercial
Channel we've taken highlights
particularly qriket in recent years but
we absolutely agree that if
um that the the direction of travel
towards making it a PSP benefit and um
we'd also hope including digital rights
um is the right way forwards do you
think this bill is currently drafted
Within
I don't see any reason why it couldn't
be added this sounds like the
government's a bit dithering and
deciding what to do they've not quite
made their mind up I think I think to be
first the government is it's not totally
straightforward issue I mean I think the
streaming issue is relatively easy to
deal with because you're talking there
about the live and for live coverage and
that's what the list events regime does
I don't think that's difficult to make
that change I think the other digital
rights is you know possibly slightly
more tricky and I think they're what I
my suggestion would be that there is a
secondary power for the Secretary of
State to Define other types of coverage
or other types of Rights subject to the
same regime and for that to be subject
to approval of parliament by via
secondary legislation we've been my
suggestion
thanks thank you River John
thank you and good morning everybody
um I'm hoping to return to channel 4
later on in today's questioning but
perhaps I could start
um with ITV and and you Mr uh Brooke um
let's begin on the question of
prominence a lot of people are very
concerned with prominence uh and for
people watching at home and they don't
know what that means that means when you
turn on your telly
and you're looking at a list of channels
how high up are certain channels if you
do it at the moment I checked this
morning with with Virgin and
astonishingly right up at the top is uh
or near the top is top TV which is good
very small viewing figures and wouldn't
be something I'd be particularly
recommending anybody to watch given the
daily ranting
um that you hear there from presenters
what protection do you think there needs
to be for companies like STV for example
in Scotland or ITV or others in the bill
over prominence
um look I think the the bill uh is is
trying to I think do the right thing uh
which is to ensure that uh ITV and STV
and others uh can get prominence for
their uh on on demand Services which
include uh streaming versions of our
channels and there's a very difficult
balance I think that the government's
trying to strike between making
absolutely clear that it that these
services are going to be prominent and
not just the services themselves the
apps as it were but also content within
them and the streaming services
themselves if they're if they're
provided within the app how did we end
up in a position at the moment where top
TV is right up there at the top and what
can be done
about that because that's promoting top
TV way above its position in the
National discussion its viewing figures
or any other criteria by which one would
judge a broadcaster yeah look I mean Mr
Christie you put your finger on a really
important point which is I suspect there
is a commercial relationship somehow or
other between uh that channel and the
platform
um and that that is the the the the the
the nature of the problem that we're
going to have to deal with increasingly
what do you want in this bill to address
that well I think I think what we've got
in the bill is a clear obligation on
platforms to make services like STV
Player or itvx prominent on platforms
and content within it to be prominent
what there isn't in the bill is enormous
amounts of detail about exactly what
prominence means so it is different for
a world which we have at the moment with
the Communications bill where you have
the concept of an EPG written into
primary legislation I think that's
something that we're all quite Keen to
avoid because there isn't such a a fixed
Concept in the world that's hurtling
towards us in terms of Internet TV what
we need are a set of principles I think
in the in the bill and some detail
around things like the fact that
algorithms can't override prominence
which is a really important part of the
uh things the proposals that government
has made and then what we're going to
need is a really muscular
interpretation and implementation by
ofcom with very clear marching orders
from Parliament this is what Parliament
wants to see in terms of the prominence
of PSB uh content and players you of
course must now go and Implement that
through a muscular set of guidelines
which you draw up on the strength of the
legislation that Parliament passes I
think that's the right way to do it
because I think the problem otherwise is
you'll end up with a piece of
legislation that's out of date before
it's even gone through Parliament
because the number of ways in which in
which platforms make content prominent
or not in this new world are so varied
from recommendations to voice search to
other forms of search to the prominence
of apps to all sorts of surfacing in
various other various other contexts so
you're going to have to have a much more
subtle and sophisticated approach I
think okay now as the chair has
explained uh we're going to the boss of
ITV before us very soon to talk about
the the news story that's dominating at
the moment but I think it'd be very odd
if we had somebody senior like yourself
from ITV without asking a couple of
questions about
um the the the the the the story about
this morning I suppose I should ask
first of all are you okay
yes yes I'm fine thank you because I
know that's that's the question du jour
at this morning
um I I spent some time at the weekend
talking to whistleblowers from ITV
including people who work and have
worked in this morning it seems like a
very unhappy place
um are you satisfied with the duty of
care
that the editorial team and Senior
managers provide to staff especially
young staff working there and at ITV
more generally
um I mean I I think there's a there's a
uh a very sophisticated uh and a
significant system of safeguarding and
duty of Care at ITV with a very
significant set of policies and we have
a a code of conduct which sets out our
expectations about how people behave and
that deals with a number of different
issues from equal opportunities to
respect at work dignity and
understanding and then we we then have
an important set of requirements which
hold people to account internally why
are so many of the staff so unhappy
former and current staff
I can't answer that question at the
moment Mr Nicholson as you know we've
also appointed uh uh Jane Mulcahy a KC
to have a look at the circumstances yes
I know you already had an inquiry and of
course and we'll come on to this on the
14th in more detail but several of the
claims that ITV made by their previous
inquiry don't seem to quite hold water
on closer inspection what do you make
about the bullying allegations that
we've heard over the last week
do I make of them yeah what do you make
what do you make of them as a senior ITV
um of official what do you feel when you
hear stuff complain about bullying
because that's the worst thing you can
possibly hear surely yeah as a senior
manager now look we take our
responsibilities in relation to
safeguarding and duty of care very
seriously bullying is absolutely in
breach of our code of conduct it's very
clearly set out we have a set of
policies around bullying bullying and
harassment at work and clearly it's
unacceptableying is unacceptable if we
if we find if we find bullying it's
inconsistent with our policy we'd expect
people to report it and we'd expect it
to be dealt with appropriately reported
in the first instance would be the
editor of the program now we also
yesterday that surreal performance by
the editor of the program who when he
was being asked by a reporter from Sky
about bullying on the program started
talking about aubergines
it was surreal and bizarre I think most
people watching that would have thought
this is the person who's responsible for
safeguarding young staff he's being
outrageously dismissive and flippant on
camera about an immensely serious issue
I wouldn't like to be a young staffer
going and talking to that editor about
bullying given that that's the way he
treats the subject matter on camera in
public
let me reassure you Mr Nicholson that we
take it we take these issues very
seriously
well I would I wouldn't endorse what he
said uh in fact I I I I wouldn't use
that word uh what word would you use I
I'd certainly say it was very it was
extremely ill-judged uh to say what he
did but look I can reassure you on
behalf of ITV that we do take all of
these allegations very seriously
precisely because we do have a culture
in which people's conduct it matters
enormously is his position secure after
that that's not a question for for me
and it's not a question for now as you
know one of the one of the ways in which
we're demonstrating that we're taking
this seriously is by appointing a very
senior Casey who's got very significant
experience in dealing with HR issues and
particularly sensitive investigations
um because there are multiple things we
have to take into account here around
privacy and so on as you will appreciate
and it's appropriate that actually the
KC establishes the facts gets to the
bottom of of what's happened and that's
exactly what we're doing okay thank you
thank you John uh Giles thank you yes I
I too have questions on that issue but I
shall leave them until Carolyn McCall
comes before us in a week or so's time
but uh following on from uh John
Nicholson's comments on prominence
um it is said that for a public service
broadcaster to benefit from prominence
and I'm going first to you Magnus if I
may
um it must be designated as an inverted
commas an internet program Service uh an
IPS
um
it has to be uh to be readily
discoverable
it's a bit of a wishy-washy term what is
what does that mean to you when you say
register do you mean the PSP content
within the service yes yes
um well I think I think um I mean let me
give you an example at the moment so if
you take ice if you've gone to itvx at
the moment and you're looking to find
last night's news program all you need
to do is scroll down the home page of
our service in order to find uh the news
that the news content uh from ITV so I
think is it is it is it is it quick to
find it is it easy to find it
um do you have to search 10 times and
put in different you know different
words into the search function or can
you actually browse and find the content
relatively easily but in a sense I can
put your mind at rest from an ITV point
of view because
I mean I think about 70 or so of itvx's
content is originated UK content it's
not all first run but it's originated UK
content which absolutely would meet the
remit that we're set by Parliament as a
public service broadcaster so our entire
purpose at itvx is to make our PSB
content as prominent as we can because
in truth that's why people come to ITV
they're not coming for uh content they
can find elsewhere they're coming for
very distinctive British content and
therefore I can absolutely assure you
that that content is going to be the
most prominent content on our service
and part of what we're providing is news
and actually the interesting thing on
news on icvx is we've had really quite
good audiences for news on itvx if you
take the first four months we've had on
average about eight million views of
streamed and on-demand news on itvx
since we launched quite a lot of that is
streamed viewing but some of it's on
demand but we've also had six million
views or so in the first four months for
our short form content on itvs because
one of the things we're experimenting
with is that are there other news for
problems that we can build an audience
for Via itvx which aren't necessarily
about having to go the day after and
watching on demand the the news program
from the day before are the more
imaginative ways we can repackage
individual items and put them up and so
on and we're experimenting with that
which feels much more in keeping with
how people consume news online rather
than watching an entire long-form
program a day after you seem to be very
happy with with the way that the bill is
is dealing with this
promotional aspect the readily
discoverable uh aspect of it all I mean
but is it a Level Playing Field I go to
Paramount on this I've got to go to
Mitchell on this is it a Level Playing
Field for you do
yeah I think
um we obviously have a all of us on this
table you know channel five in
particular has a very much its peak
schedule is very much originated and it
fits in that
um factual genre that's our kind of
go-to I think the two areas if you if
you want to go and binge watch uh uh
Susan kalman's Grand days out you're
able to do that and it's easily readily
findable in the service I think one
thing that we are perhaps slightly
differentiated from our from those in
the state was obviously children's
content so if you want to go and catch
up on Peppa Pig or you want to catch up
on someone's tank engine then clearly my
five is a space that um you know parents
and families are able to do that so we
we think that the bill is broadly
correct in this in terms of making sure
and keeping us holding us to account as
it were that within our VOD Services the
PSP content is suitably findable and
accessible and clearly of com
um will have powers to provide guidance
to us to ensure that we are being held
to count on this so we think uh broadly
speaking we're happy okay that's a good
deal Khalid you're nodding yeah well
it's a similar points and a I mean for
us to try to fall you know we deliver
our remit through all of our services
and we and we consider we deliver our
remit through our content as a whole and
you know within our channel for
streaming app so it's recently rebranded
from all four you know as Magnus
describes we you know we think about the
app in order to hit in order to help you
don't think you know design of the app
you know think about how do viewers
navigate through and find the content
they need but we also have you know what
we call at the top of the hero Carousel
I.E the titles that we're promoting at
the top of at the top of the app at the
top of the home screen which you know
which will include in the most popular
content you know which provides a
Gateway into more challenging Public
Service genres but but also we apply a
public service overlay in the remit
Dimension to how we think about what
we're recommending at the top of the app
so so we absolutely think about you know
surfacing the right PSB content and you
know and challenging content through the
app and then as Magnus described
The Wider regulatory regime has the pre
takes uh sorry the video bill has the
principles of of ensuring that the app
as a whole gets prominence and the live
PSB live streams get prominence and the
PSP content gets prominence in the user
interfaces into which we're placing
those apps and again what you know
whilst we think there are areas which
the regime could be strengthened
particularly in relation to the
agreement objectives and of dispute
resolution the principles the sensible
ones uh which we want which we want off
Contour so that again the areas which
yes so the area today the area where we
think that their strengthening required
is is what it could investors the
agreement objectives you know in the
event that off companies to intervene so
what I mean by that is is is is clear
this is about prominence for PSB apps
and PSB Services PSP content but but
it's also about securing fair value in
relation to our relationships with
platforms and and the require and the
regime will require that we as the psbs
only go or we use Channel 4 and
negotiating with a platform in in in in
relation to prominence and access to our
contents and services and in the event
that we fail to an agreement with the
platform then ofcom has a role to play
as a backstop in order to intervene in
order to ensure that prominence is still
view that to carry out for off gun yeah
yes so of course we'll have that role
the way the draft Bill describes those
objectives at present it frames it in
terms of off-com needing to take into
account the costs associated with Public
Service delivery and we think that
applying cost is too narrow because
actually we think the policy intention
and indeed offcomes a recommendation is
that is that prominence should be
provided on terms that are consistent
with sustainable delivery of Public
Service obligations so what we think
that needs to be needs to be considered
in that in those agreement objectives is
that it needs to take into account the
value of PSB delivery and the value that
the PSB content provides to these
platforms so that when in the event that
oftcom does have to intervene it can
take that broader value to it into
account not just the costs associated
with delivery a very good point thank
you very much um I'd like to talk about
a video on demand Services
um and on this I think Magnus I come to
you um on what basis do you decide which
content to give prominence to on video
on demand
well look it's a mixture of things I
think that um fairly obviously where
we've got a new drama that we've
invested uh uh a a you know a small
fortune in uh and we're very proud of
and it's got some top talent we will
want to make that prominent because we
want to tell viewers about it and we
want them to watch it so there are some
fairly obvious things like that I think
there are there are other considerations
around the audience so are we do our do
our numbers show that we're reaching all
of the audience
um do we need to Target particular
segments of the audience more than
perhaps we have been uh so one of the
things we're trying to do with itvx is
is reach more like what we call light
viewers so people who don't haven't
necessarily come to ITV as much over the
past few years can we get them back into
ITV and so we'll look quite carefully at
the sort of content that those viewers
like and then we'll we'll try and make
that prominent but as I say I mean we've
we've got a pretty prominent news rail
on the service and and news's news is
bringing quite a bit of traffic you said
earlier in the session that of course
you are a commercial operation I mean
there must be commercial considerations
to prominence of course of course and
and say the light audience point is is
absolutely about that because it's about
the reach of our services and one of the
things advertisers are interested in is
is yes volume but also reach are we
reaching uh as as much of the UK
population as we can uh with our with
our advertising so that's absolutely uh
part of what we're trying to because the
advertisers will go to where the uh
prominence is and we'll go to the uh I
mean the reason prominence matters is
because it does drive a bigger audience
of course it creates more um it creates
more eyeballs for advertisers the
question I really want to put again I'm
using the term again is is there a Level
Playing Field across the ground here I
mean because everybody is is is looking
for the same pool of advertisers who
want to come to their to their streaming
service their video on demand whatever
and and they want to make sure there's a
Level Playing Field and the question I'm
fundamentally asking is does this bill
do that and I'll go to you Magellan
um yeah I don't think we have any
challenges to build on magnus's point
slightly and not procedures at all but
but you know if you take for example
um you know PSP players the billboard
Services have a huge wealth of content
many thousands of hours and obviously we
want to support the PSP meeting content
on top but equally our commercial driven
organization so it won't be uncommon
particular on my five that as you move
towards Christmas you will start to see
a rail of Christmas movies and it will
bring people in but the point being that
that commercial type content or the
Christmas movies will bring people into
a PSP service and then when they're
there they'll be able to maybe move on
to watch some of the content that was
previously shown on Channel 5 as as more
kind of traditional PSP content so what
we're trying to do is both hit our um
our objectives as a PSB to reflect
people's lives back to themselves but at
the same time create a proposition a
customer value proposition that is
commercially orientated and helps us to
then generate Revenue that can reinvest
back into content fantastic very honest
answer yeah I mean look in terms of the
Level Playing Field point I don't think
the prominence regime is is intending to
or seek into override consumer choice I
mean ultimately viewers will watch what
they want to watch but but we as the UK
have taken the view that public service
content matters and public service
broadcasting matters and therefore we
all think that public service content
should be easy to find so that viewers
can Discover it and and ultimately they
make the choices and inform choices that
they want to make okay thank you
gentlemen thank you chair thank you uh
Jane thank you chair um good morning
um I want to turn to um selection
services and smart TVs and how people
are accessing uh content the bill aims
to capture selection services but it
doesn't cover mobile phones and uh
tablets and other devices the BBC said
that a quarter of content hours on
iPlayer in 22
um were accessed on other devices that
would fall outside the bill so I'd like
to ask it do you do you think that needs
closing is it the loophole that you're
concerned about Magnus
I mean yes um to an extent
um I think that what you can see in the
market is is that the the the accessing
through tablets and computers is going
down
um quite quite rapidly and actually
people are now increasingly watching on
TV like devices I think there are
devices
um do you if you like dual use devices
particularly um gaming consoles and so
on there is more of a question about
whether the bill to cover those but I
think we I think we think that the bill
currently will cover the majority of of
itvx's viewing
um and so I think we uh of course we'd
prefer as if it went further but I think
uh I don't think we're we're desperately
uncomfortable uh with where the
government's ended up and it would make
a more General point which is you know
we're talking a lot here about the the
defects if you like in the bill I think
there's a stepping back for a second I
mean we think the bill is broadly
speaking going absolutely in the right
direction I think the definition of
selection service is quite flexible and
there is a possibility in future that
that could be broadened out if if
viewing Behavior changes and one of the
things we're keen is to make sure
actually is that things that might be
excluded at the beginning could
potentially come back in if it turns out
that we're wrong and that people do do
carry on and indeed viewing through
tabletting tablets increase for example
or or let's say YouTube I mean let's say
you know imagine YouTube start providing
what looks like a television selection
service because they start aggregating
together lots of Television on-demand
Television services together it would be
entirely appropriate for YouTube at
those that at that point to be covered
by the bill and it seems to me there's
nothing in the bill at the moment that
would stop that from happening it may
not well not be the case uh an
adjustment at the beginning but but
important the important thing is that we
have a bill that's capable of extending
uh to those platforms which I think the
bill is I think the only thing it rules
out is the button the remote control
because I think the government's view is
that that took them into territory uh
International Trade territory which
could cause difficulty but that's the
that seems to me the hardware exception
as it were in the bill is is the main
area which isn't going to change but but
actually the rest of it is sufficiently
flexible to change over time
colored yeah I agree with all of that
and and again as with ITV we we you know
we'd clearly prefer to be prominent on
as many platforms and devices as
possible but it does feel right that you
know when you look out there in the
consumer landscape the real Battleground
for once for better term is in terms of
smart TV operating systems you know it
is Samsung LG Google TV uh yeah you know
Roku is obviously small in the UK but
big in the US and so on and so forth so
it's a prioritizing big screen devices
you know it it does does feel reasonable
and and and will capture uh the core
reviewing but but yeah but but
absolutely agree that look the the bill
is proposing a principles-based regime
with flexibility to evolve over time and
and we're therefore supportive of that
I don't have anything to eat I mean we
we're sympathetic to the idea that
government must try and draw a boundary
somewhere and we think that they've
probably done it in the right place and
that the inbuilt flexibility for
audience changes welcomed in the future
thank you
um a little on Legacy Services
um is the bill sufficiently clear on
whether ofcom could remove a legacy
selection service
um when something's sort of outdated and
not receiving technical updates those
very old platforms do you think there's
gaps it is it isn't quiet actually and
this is a this is a slight concern we
have in the sense that when we we know
this through this first-hand experience
of launching itvx last year which is
when you if you think of a platform I
don't know Samsung you think it's a
single platform and therefore actually
if you write Samsung on the list it will
be fine because you'll be able to have a
must offer obligation on on us and a
mass carry obligation on that but
actually Samsung is not a single
platform it's a it's a set of different
platforms over time all under the same
umbrella but some of them were different
operating systems and some of them
frankly are not supported by Samsung
anymore as we discovered and therefore
it was literally technically impossible
to put itvx on some of those Legacy
platforms they are all older platform
forms it either was literally impossible
technically or it was economically
entirely unfeasible at
partly because the software simply
couldn't support the sophistication of
the service that we were we were
offering so I do think it's really
important that we put this in our
submission to the committee uh that
there is discretion for ofcom uh to say
actually there are certain certain
variance if you like of platforms that
we may designate that don't have to be
covered by this obligation to offer and
carry because it wouldn't be appropriate
and we we've we tried very hard on the
launch of itpx and we got we got nearly
to 100 but didn't quite get to 100 of
all of the platforms that ITV Hub had
been on because there were some we
simply couldn't work out how how we
could get it on and look at the platform
in quite the cases
thank you do you think that needs to be
a case-by-case basis though of course
yeah I think so I think so because
because you know I
would definitely say look Samsung Smart
TVs need to be on the list
um uh and and various other um
manufacturers
um what I don't what I think is probably
impractical is to have a list that's 35
pages long of a list literally list not
the 2015 variants and so on I think that
I think it's it's right that there
should be a discretion for offcom uh to
say actually because of practical
difficulty it it shouldn't apply uh to
the following models or whatever in
practice
thank you Kelly yeah I I agree with
agree with all that so I absolutely
agree with that that principle that it's
an area of companies look at and there
needs to be flexibility and you know I
think it's fair to say that that
operationally we see and we encounter
these these kind of issues ourselves in
in in in areas and platforms where we as
the PSPs have a stake so you know so
we're all you know all of our
organizations are are
um shareholders in everyone TV formerly
known as digital UK which operates
freesat and uh you know we're all part
of we're all part of you view and
actually we do see the different devices
you know have different technical
specifications and therefore our Tech
and product teams do and do end up
engaging in bespoke work in order to
enable delivery on those devices so
absolutely as as in this increasing
competition the device landscape
increasing proliferation of of devices
that does create complexity which should
be taken into account in in the in in
the way the regulatory regime is applied
thank you Mitchell yeah I would just I
just said I mean I read some of the uh
responses to this to this inquiry over
the weekend and I think it was struck by
the fact that actually on this point
specifically actually many of the
platforms also have some of the same
concerns and it would seem odd that if
if in a kind of mustoffer must carry
regime we could potentially a situation
where both a
um a PSB and a platform both struggling
to make the technological requirements
in order to have that PSP on the on the
said specific platform and yet there's
not the flexibility in the regime to say
actually this is a 29 uh you know 2009
type type TV that's only got you know we
we need to have that flexibility and
often me to be able to make the
judgments because it does feel like
there's actually there may be some
consensus in the industry
thank you so the other side of it is
um having an annual release and sort of
avoiding regulation from uh from there
well I I guess it will it'll need to be
a judgment made by ofcom in terms of you
know which specific devices have still
got the um suitable proliferation
amongst viewers and also we as PSPs are
able to make reach the correct
technological hurdles to make our
products available to them and I don't
think it will work no expert on this
matter but my subjects will not be at a
purely linear environment you just say
oh after 10 years there's no you know
there could be some devices which are
much more popular a year is much more
popular than another so I think it does
need to be flexibility but clearly it's
in the interest of both psbs and the
platforms to make sure there's a regime
that addresses the issue of Legacy
devices thank you so flexibility under
offcome basically it sorry if I could
just add something which which really
did strike Us in the course of the
launch of itvx was uh I think it could
consumers haven't quite realized yet
that televisions are basically computers
and whereas people think about how long
a computer would typically last and I
think people's expectation televisions
last for ages mine's only 10 years old
um and it's sort of 10 years in my life
I've imagined using your computer that
you had 10 years ago
um it is and so I think there is a there
is something that all of us need to do
to help educate consumers that these are
different things now when you have a
connected TV thank you thank you thank
you Jim thank you
thank you um I just want to ask about uh
they must offer must carry agreement
objectives do you think the bill as it's
drafted meets the overall agreement
objectives between a regulated
television selection service and a
public sector broadcaster I don't know
I'll come to you man I'm happy to go
first uh no I don't I don't think they
do quite at the moment so I think the
basic setup of a must carry must offer
uh regime as it were is the right one
and I think you do have to have a
dispute resolution function in case we
can't agree and in a sense to reassure
you what we're looking to do is have a
commercial agreement with the platform
so a partnership a win-win where we
benefit and they benefit that's what
we're looking to do and we definitely
have those sorts of relationships with
sky and with Virgin now and that's what
we want to replicate we in our
relationship with them we sell our
advertising we have our relationships
with our advertisers we can innovate in
how we offer things like Planet V which
is our programmatic advertising uh
platform and we can use data to help
Target our advertising on ITV more
effectively within those Partnerships so
that's what we're looking to do what we
see coming down the track I think are
and this is specific to internet
television are a set of internet
television platforms who will apply or
try to apply a set of terms globally and
those terms are going to be pretty
stringent they're going to require us to
give away at least 30 percent of our
Revenue so Revenue not profit to them
simply by being on the platform they'll
require us effectively to go into their
advertising system so we won't
necessarily have a relationship with
advertisers we we won't be able to
innovate in terms of our ad Tech we
won't necessarily have access to any
data that's the threat that's coming and
and I wouldn't want to understate this I
mean that is an existential threat to
PSB and there is no other way of putting
it I mean a third of our revenue is
equivalent to more or less approaching
what we spend in time in its entirety
out of London in a single year so that's
the threat that's coming so we need to
do we need to make sure or that the
dispute resolution regime enables ofcom
to have enough enough strength and
enough discretion to avoid that outcome
and to get us into a place of a win-win
in the way that we have with a virgin or
a sky that's what we would like and at
the moment the second agreement
objective which talks only about cost we
think is not the right approach because
effectively what it says is all the PSB
can expect from that relationship is to
get its costs back and therefore from
our point of view we we're a commercial
business if we have a hit we don't just
want to get our costs back we want to
make a bit more money so we can reinvest
in original content similarly if we want
to innovate as we are doing in
advertising and in data in programmatic
advertising or in our relationships that
we built over many years with our
advertisers we want to be able to have
that relationship not the platform and
the danger with the formulation at the
moment is its Winner Takes all for the
platform Beyond cost and as a business
we can't simply get our costs back we
have to make a profit we want to
innovate we want to do a build on the
relationship or our advertisers so we
think that that agreement objective
needs to be recast it's really really
important I can't emphasize it enough
how important it is for that for that
agreement objective to brewery cast and
we put some proposed uh drafting to the
committee
um which I can which I can describe but
broadly speaking what we're suggesting
is that that ofcom has discretion to
ensure uh or to look at other
arrangements that we have with other
players say with a virgin or a sky let's
say in order to make sure and I use I
use Sky's words here actually that this
agreement this agreement objective ought
to protect the psbs from from
unreasonable demands from the platforms
I've never heard Skye talk about
protecting psbs from unreasonable
demands but that that even there you use
that language so so first bit of it I
think is that ofcom needs to be able to
look at other arrangements to say okay
is what this platform is saying is that
consistent with other arrangements that
that we as a PSP have in place I think
the second is that we ought to have the
potential to be able to make the most of
our investment in our content in terms
of getting the value from hits in terms
of innovation in terms of use of data so
we want to be able to fulfill the
potential of our business and I think it
may be that cost is a backstop in other
words no lower than cost as a sort of as
a kind of basic backstop but it but it
has to go further than that give us more
potential uh to achieve uh uh success
with our business and our on our own
merits and I think the third one is that
I've come all to be able to to have a
look at whether an agreement materially
weakens the business of itvx because if
if in the end the agreement is one-sided
an itvx can't innovate and advertise it
can't innovate in data it's forced to go
into someone else's system
um that's not an agreement that is going
to result in a sustainable PSB system
going forwards and I I think it was um
dcms who said that the purpose of this
is to improve PSP sustainability it's
not going to do that if we simply have
cost as the criteria because every
platform will simply go and say what's
your cost what's your cost of the
programs right okay let's allocate that
across all the platforms we'll give you
that cost and you and you can frankly
take everything single other term that
we want to impose on you it can't be
right because we're obliged to spread
the service you you mentioned sky and
there seems to be
um concerns from both sides of this
argument about this particular area of
the bill is there any consensus coming
from the industry itself between you
know the well I think there's a broad
consensus as much as the asbs and what I
what I haven't done is is uh ask Skye
about the proposed amendments we've made
I have to say we we've drafted those in
a way which which as far as I'm
concerned uh meets Sky's test of
protecting psbs from unreasonable
demands from the platforms and and they
people like they in virgin who who have
a constructive partnership approach not
a cookie cutter these are the terms but
a genuine look how can we both win from
this relationship I didn't think they
have anything to worry about from these
Arrangements
um I mean you'll have to ask them but
but it's very deliberately been drafted
with what we see coming down the track I
have to say mainly from the US
um of this one-size-fits all this is
these are the terms that's what we're
particularly concerned about and that's
why we've constructed the proposed
amendments in the way that uh the way
that we have it's not about sky and
virgin we'd be really happy to have
conversations with them about about how
we can make sure that it does one thing
and all the other because we want to get
to a commercial deal and to be really
clear a commercial deal or partnership
deal we don't want of con to intervene
we grow a commercial negotiation because
that these These are complicated
relationships there are lots of facets
to them whether that's data or
technology and all the rest of it and
they're much better negotiated than
imposed by a regulator but what we as I
say what we're worried about just in
case I haven't said it already uh is is
this one-size-fits-all approach that we
can see uh very graphic and and it's
nearly here I mean we we had a devil of
a job with itvx
negotiating uh some of those demands
yeah if you have anything to it yeah I
mean I agree this looks very closely to
my response to Mr watling's earlier
question yeah yeah it was I think it was
off Club it recommended that PSB should
be made available on terms that are
consistent with sustainable delivery of
Public Service obligations as Magna says
a cost recovery based approach is not is
not it's not consistent with that with
that objective uh you know we need to we
need to take a look at PSP value in the
round
yeah but I think I
I'll you know we currently have
um positive deals with those such as sky
and virgin what essentially one is what
we have now on these new platforms are a
bit more prominent it's not it's not
hugely complicated I don't think in the
way that we think about these things but
the reality is
um we're not able to to do that at the
moment and this legislation should
hopefully help us do that I do think
that
um as Magnus has alluded to and and
Khalid as well the the language could be
tightened and nuanced in the legislation
but the overall principle that is set
out we think is broadly correct
thank you very much uh David thank you
Chad
um I want to ask a couple questions
about channel four uh if I may
specifically and starting with Clause 24
which
sets out the duty of long-term
sustainability and which puzzles me a
bit if I step back from the whole debate
over the past couple of years about
privatization in that the 1990
broadcasting act says the duty of the
borders to keep Channel 4 sustainable at
one of the duties and indeed generally
companies act legislation of 2006
companies act says that any board has a
duty to make their firms successful
um so what what is added by this new
sustainability Duty yeah so
so I think I think I think I think it's
correct to say that the the members of
the channel for Corporation the board
directors you know I absolutely do
comply with directors duties
um you know as if they were directors of
companies by way of the companies act uh
2006. and and and we do that through
their contracts of Engagement and via
the fact that c4c is a corporation is
run to conform with the UK corporate
governance code
um but but in the discussions with with
dcms and government around uh the
package that was announced in in in in
January you know a the government the
government had a priorities to set out
explicitly in legislation a member a a
duty on the directors to promote
Financial
sustainability of channel four we're
comfortable with that principle and you
know and and the principle of adding in
a clause on that basis what we have been
doing is having some discussion with
with these dcms around the precise
wording of that clause in order to
ensure that does have unintended
consequences I mean I'm I'm still
puzzled does it add anything
are your directors going to behave in
any different way because of this clause
and the way they're already behaving so
the the directors are required to
fulfill the primary functions of Channel
4 which includes delivery of the core
channel for um main Channel
and and and and therefore our our
proposal uh preference would be that
yeah if there is sustainability clause
in the media building a per section 24
you know we would want that to refer
more directly to the to the primary
functions of Channel 4. and you know and
to be and to make sure they aligned with
the company's act 2006 particularly uh
section 172.
either you would prefer it if it didn't
change much well of your existing
movement not well the the intention as
we understand it is is in order to
codify the requirement on the members of
the corporation to support and ensure
the financial sustainability of channel
four uh you know you know we're
comfortable with that if you know where
it's consistent with delivery of the
primary functions of the corporation
okay I mean part of it is to sustain the
activities long term so you must have
thought this through how long is long
term
what what you know in terms of how we
think about the longer term and how we
think about the the business you know we
you know we've we've got a strategy to
transfer transform Channel 4 into a
digital first Public Service Media
organization you know our future four
strategy which is about prioritizing
digital growth and about and about
diversifying revenue streams we've set
ourselves specific Targets on the on
those uh on that strategy for 2025 to
double the size of our streaming service
in audience terms to to grow digital
advertising to 30 of our total revenues
by 2025 to to grow non-advertising
revenues to be 10 of total revenues by
2025 and we're making good progress
against those targets you know as we
look Beyond 2025 you know we haven't set
four more targets for the rest of decade
but as far as weeks are the principles
of that strategy remain as we look into
Channel 4 over the rest this decade into
the next decade over the next of com
license period we do need to think about
the fact that by the time you get to the
internet slices period you know you know
Channel 4 will continue to be delivering
live linear content but will be
increasingly a streaming based
organization a streaming-based
proposition and delivering Public
Service content on streaming and social
platforms so we need so so the business
needs flexibility in order to enable and
support that Evolution
and and this sustainability Duty needs
to be consistent with that and and you
know and so one area where we have
expressed some concern is around the
language or in in in in the in the
drafting around level of activities so
activities is not clearly defined level
of activities would appear to or could
run the risk of limiting the ways in
which we can evolve what we're doing in
terms of how we're delivering the remit
to for in the interest of viewers and
again I come back to this which is why
linking to primary functions we think
would would would work better because
primary functions of c4c is more clearly
defined in existing legislation and and
obviously there is as it were precedent
there so you would prefer the bill
basically not to tie you down too much
is that well or or there is or there is
well that well there is well rehearsed
and clear definitions of channel 4's
primary functions and duties and
therefore ensuring commercial
sustainability and delivery of those
duties and those functions would appear
to be a reasonable Way Forward
and one of the obviously the biggest
specific change is the the abolition of
the publisher podcast the split
um
do you think that's particularly helpful
for your long-term sustainability but
for you to become more of a
publish a broadcaster I mean listen so
we um the independent production sector
is you know is the lifeblood of Channel
4 we have spent the last 40 years
working very closely with partners with
our partners in the independent
production sector you know they they are
they are our lifeblood we don't make our
own content and we never have made our
content for for channel 4.
um you know and and I and as this
committee will be aware a change to the
publisher broadcaster status is not
something that we called for during the
dcms consultation into the future
ownership of channel four
um but but but it's a it's a decision
that the government made in order to
give Channel 4 the flexibility and
optionality to to make its own programs
in future if that's what we want to do
and and we accept that proposal but what
but what we do say is that you know you
know in you know in the event that the
publisher broadcast restriction is
removed of course that requires the
media Bill to pass in the event that is
the publishing broadcast restriction is
removed you know we don't have any
in-house production at present it would
take time to to build up and we would do
it in a way that that is you know it
would have to be the both the business
case and the public policy aspects and
the commissioning aspects and The Wider
stakeholder relationship aspects would
have to be carefully considered have you
decided yet are you assuming the bill
passes in roughly its current form that
you will definitely go down that route
you'll make your own content I'm very
transparent with you what we're doing is
is you know we're looking at the
Strategic options available to channel 4
in the event that the public that the
Restriction is removed and you know and
and and as we look across the market we
see there's a whole host of ways in
which organizations have built up in our
in-house production or or or
intellectual property-based activities
you know you can you can build up from
scratch you know and therefore have a
Greenfield organic growth as it were and
you know and that is an option but but
obviously that requires a lot of
Investments you know production margins
can be quite tight an organization
Channel 4 doesn't currently have the the
capabilities in-house in order to to do
that quickly so that would be gradual
and take time you know as ITV grew as it
resources grew it's it's already large
production business ITV did a lot of
growth through acquisitional production
companies now again that's an option of
potentially available but you know we
have a debt limit we don't have those
level of resources in order to go big on
something like that so you know there
are other ways you can look at
Partnerships and joint ventures for
example to help uh Drive
um intellectual property growth so you
know we don't have a set Way Forward
we're exploring the options and
discussing those with our board but
we're also interested in in
understanding where government is going
to come out in the process that dcms is
engaging with on with a with a wider
production sector in order to help
understand the impact of the product on
the production sector of of this change
because we share the government's
objective that whilst there's been
there's benefit to channel 4 in Greater
commercial flexibility from this change
it needs to be managed in a way that is
consistent with a continued flourishing
independent production sector and and
with that interview as a as a final
probe
um are you at the stage out of thinking
what kind of quota of your own content
you you would want to make is it 20 or
whatever yeah I mean we we we we we
don't we don't have a fixed view because
we because again we're thinking through
these strategic options as to kind of
want as to what uh you know what
in-house production might look like in
the event that we did it
um you know I mean the government is
thinking about my you know is there a
need for additional protections and
mitigations for the production sector in
the event of this change and uh you know
and should that involve any changes to
quotas and so on and so forth and you
know we think ultimately that's a matter
of government in order to reach its view
based on its consideration of the pros
and cons but I mean our our general
starting point here is that look is that
if the government is wishing to give
optionality and potential commercial
flexibility to channel 4 then then a
proportionate Way Forward would be to
give that flexibility but you know but
but and and allow of Commerce the sector
regulator to consider what what
protections and mitigation might be
needed in order in order to to enable
those to evolve over time as needed
rather than set any additional
mitigations in legislation for instance
in order to put the fixed at this point
in time and therefore make them harder
to evolve but and then the more broader
point in which again we have we have
made dcos is that is that if you go if
you dcms if the government wants Channel
4 potentially to generate value from
having flexibility from having the
commercial Freedom and flexibility in
this area the more onerous the
additional restrictions that are placed
on Channel 4 in the event of this change
the harder it is to sustain to develop
commercially sustainable business case
thank you just ignore that that's just
the
Parliamentary day starting uh can I just
press you on that a little bit we
clearly colored in a different place
that we thought we'd be in this piece of
legislation regarding channel four
uh but there's no doubt that you're
still facing some considerable
challenges you know you've got well I
mean as you as you can say a kind of
business model based upon paying others
to make your product and then
effectively letting them keep the
profits you've got huge overheads at a
time when advertising revenues are being
sucked up by many of your streaming
competitors huge
wage bills of a CEO reportedly on 1.4
million pounds a year the highest in the
Network's history and
um canceling shows at the 11th Hour
reportedly as well what's the plan I
mean is Channel 4 genuinely sustainable
for the future in the long term yeah my
size point would you say that the
channel 4 is in very strong creative
Health you know we we you know we you
know you'll have seen we we recently won
uh nine bafta Awards the the the most
people in 22 years uh you know for for
programming like I am Ruth Derry girls
on our Ukraine news coverage you know in
in in film we've had 40 nominations at
the big film Awards we've won eight
Awards so we're in very strong creative
Health the the the the the the the the
the the pressures that you describe in
relation to some of the some of the
commissioning decisions that we've
recently made for instance you know they
are short-term Market pressures you know
we're all of us as commercial
broadcasters or commercially funded
broadcasters are experiencing pressures
of the ad Market relating to the
economic conditions that we find
ourselves in as the UK
um and our priority throughout this
period is to preserve shows as much as
we can is to minimize any disruption or
you know all cancellations to
commissioning
um you know and any and any decisions
that we make are are about in ensuring
the sustainability and delivering
sustainability of of Channel Force
remake delivery
um and and actually and actually in 2022
2022 was the record year for Content
investment for Channel 4 we invested
more in 2022 than we did any other year
and we're actually going to invest a
similar amount of content this year but
what we are doing is phasing our
activity a bit a bit more and given the
market conditions that we find ourselves
in so actually I would so I would I
would say that that the activities that
we're having to take in the short term
whilst we absolutely acknowledge are are
painful for some of our suppliers and
and and and we're very grateful to them
for working with us through this period
that they are they are activities that
reflect short-term market conditions
they're not they don't reflect in any
way any concerns about long-term
sustainability and what we will be doing
shortly is is briefing in these on our
2024 and 2025 commissioning needs we'll
be briefing these on that later this
year in order to give forward visibility
of our of our commissioning is going
forward
and thank you yes could I come in uh
perhaps with uh with you uh
um
this is the second time with since I
joined parliament in 2015 we've fought
off uh privatization of channel four
um I hope this is the last time that uh
that you have to do it
but it's quite odd isn't the The Fallout
from it you don't really want these
changes
do you
well look Channel 4 is a publicly owned
asset it's entirely reasonable for the
government from time to time to look at
whether whether the right whether the
current model the current ownership
model is the right model and and and
whether you think it's the right model
don't you well we so so through through
the consultation process we we saw our
role as providing evidence and Analysis
to set out the implication for remit
delivery I can see what we really want
is for you as a government to allow us
to make our own programs you didn't say
that at any point well we we we
set out the implications or the impacts
on remit delivery of potential changes
to the model so what's happened am I
right is the government in order to
justify this whole long process of
looking at Channel 4 and looking
privatizing Channel 4 it can't simply
Retreat and say well that was a complete
waste of time we're walking away from it
Channel 4 is one they've got to have a
fake Leaf to sure they've achieved
something and the Fig leaf to be that
you're not going to be allowed forced to
make your own programs except you're not
going to do it are you so
look you'll have to ask the government
about about this but I'm asking you at
this precise moment but my but thank you
but my yeah but you know my
understanding is that the in in order to
2022 uh secondly the Secretary of State
made a decision to re-examine the
business case for Channel 4
privatization you know we inputted into
that into that process uh the the
um uh the the business case was
re-examined the secretary looks the
evidence and took the view that
privatization of Channel 4 is not needed
in order to sustain uh the Remake
delivery it did last time it was a long
expensive process are you going to start
making programs well as I said we are
exam we are looking at the Strategic
options we do see how in over the medium
term Channel 4 only more intellectual
property and make its programs could
deliver value for channel 4. we we look
at the Strategic options working with
our board on those options whilst we're
trying to also in parallel trying to see
where government comes out in relation
to I've talked to loads of senior people
for I'll be astonished in five years
from now you're going to be making uh
your own programs I understand why you
say yes we'll look at it but in reality
um you're being given a power uh that
you're never going to use it just seems
a Monumental waste of time as part of
this bill to give you something that
you've not asked for and that you don't
want and that you'll never use
isn't that the ultimate in pointlessness
when it comes to legislation
the government is providing the
commercial flexibility and optionality
for Channel 4. it will be a matter for
Channel 4 the corporation and its ball
to decide whether and how to use that
optionality
weight with beated breasts
thank you
thank you chair and good morning
everyone
welcome to this place of warmth and
Magic to call you a phrase
um I just want to follow up as well on
on the channel for a little bit on that
I mean isn't it isn't John Nicholson
Wright in a way that that basically
privatization of Channel 4 The Proposal
in the first place was a solution in
search of a problem
and the current proposals within the
draft Media bill about Channel 4 are
exactly the same thing
a solution in search of a problem in
order that the government can save a bit
of face
over the second debacle in less than a
few years around Channel 4 privatization
that's a fair assessment isn't it the
government chose to re-examine the
business case for Channel 4
privatization and made a decision I know
and you've said that already but I mean
I'm asking you whether you would agree
with me
that basically all of this is is a is a
solution in search of a problem because
actually
there's a channel for executive I expect
you to say as you're very highly paid
chief executive has actually said to us
quite frankly on occasions
so that that that that that that you
don't agree with these proposals and
that you effectively that's what they
are a solution in search of a problem
that doesn't really exist
package it outs both the government in
in January will is intended to ensure
the long-term commercial sustainability
channel for as a as a not-for-profit
it's a publicly owned published yeah I
know and you've said all that already
but I mean is there really a problem
here that's why I'm saying that this is
a solution to
speaking for the company is there a
problem
with the current structure and
boundaries that apply to channel 4 that
this is a solution to through the
consultation process we made clear our
view that we don't see a code so the
answer then is that you don't think it
is a solution the government has decided
on this on this sustainability package
and we've welcomed the government's
announcements I know that and you've
said that already but I mean all I'm
asking you is I I thought Channel false
position on this is quite clear until
you start speaking about it and that
that is that that they thought it was
that they thought this was not something
they really particularly welcomed and
they didn't want because it didn't solve
any problem that existed but are you
saying that there is a problem that
exists
um the government obviously think is a
problem I accept that but I didn't think
Channel 4 thought there was a problem
having commercial flexibility to evolve
one's business in the future doesn't
mean there's a problem with the business
it just means there there it just means
there are there are levers available
there will be Believers available to
channel 4. channel forward decide how to
use them on the sustainability Clause
when you're when you're answering
questions from Damien green
earlier on he asked you a question which
I don't think he really answered which
was basically uh the question what
difference will the sustainability
Clause make to the way that your
director's behave in practice
the sustainability Clause will create an
obligation on the directors in the media
Bill media acts
sustainability but what difference will
it make to the way your directors behave
in practice which is what Damian green
asked you earlier on is the answer to
that no
so
we so sustainability Clause needs to be
implemented in a way that is consistent
with delivery of the primary functions
of Channel 4.
sorry that doesn't answer my question
do you expect that it you'll be your
directors to behave in any different way
than they currently do as a result of
the introduction of the sustainability
clause
there's two options to answer that yes
they will behave differently or no they
won't behave differently because they're
actually behaving in that way already
directors focus on the primary functions
of Channel 4 and it's important for that
for that Focus to remain and I
understand that and so to be honest with
you but I think I think it means that no
it won't make any difference because
they already do behave in that way in
any case
um but correct me if I'm if I'm wrong if
that's my interpretation
um of what you're saying
um
can I just ask about what you've
mentioned earlier on about
um
commissioning activity in in channel
four and and you know the difficulty of
doing that when times are tough now
during the privatization process
um Channel 4 introduced a new current
affairs program the Andrew Neal show
Andrew Neal is a brilliant political
interviewer without doubt you know I may
not agree with his politics but you know
there's undoubtedly that he is you know
top political interviewer and he was
given a show and some people suggested
that he was given that show in order to
try to call off the dogs a bit on the
right of the conservative party and from
the government around privatization to
show if you like the channel 4 wasn't
just about Channel 4 News which is a
particular bet you are of some people
um within the government and in in the
right on the right of the conservative
party
so that I think that shows had three
seasons is that going to be
recommissioned now that privatization's
off the cards
I don't make commissioning decisions for
for for channel fours I have any
information you could share with us but
what I what I'd say is that you know we
are committed to delivery of impartial
and using current affairs we are that's
the lightest obligation it's at the
heart of what we do we're absolutely
focused on that
um you know I I I add all of our news
coverage has always been found to be
impartial uh we've never been in fact
we've never been found to be in breached
with those of those license requirements
and and we see the role of channel 4
news and current affairs and public
service broadcasting in the round to
provide a range of perspectives to
provide a range of viewpoints and to
provide challenge it might be it might
be recommissioned you just don't know is
the answer to that question I just
dropped because because privatization is
off the cards I I don't make commissions
assistance Channel 4. okay
um
can I just ask about
um perhaps I'll turn to Mitchell about
the new code
that is being proposed for the new video
on demand code that's been proposed
within the media Bill what's your view
of that and and what changes do you
think that might be needed
in relation to that and if possible can
you reference any implications you might
have for coverage during election
periods
so um I should begin by saying that
parameters are a unique position in that
within the UK Market obviously is that
at the end of Republic Service
Broadcasting channel five but also
um Global streaming platform Paramount
Plus for whom we would anticipate that
the tier one standards code
um would apply I think at a general
level we are very sympathetic to the
notion that
as a viewer moves between devices that
clearly
um different regulatory regimes exist or
do not exist for some services and that
it's important that standards are upheld
across between Services because when a
when a viewer is watching on
um a PSP linear Channel and then maybe
go and watch on a escort service or then
go and watch on a single cast on another
service that the that the audience needs
to expect that they're getting a similar
delivery in terms of broadcasting
standards
um we have we we broadly welcome the
regime we think it makes sense and it's
logical
um and I say that from both a public
from from a PSB perspective it's channel
five and also
um from the Paramount plus side of the
business I think the one area that
clearly
um is interesting is this that's come up
previously is this area around in
the direct transposition maybe some
aspects of the broadcasting code into
the to the Vaude environment
clearly there are differences in the way
that we view linear content you can turn
on a TV channel and you'll just land on
something when it comes to a linear
viewing whereas on a VOD service you're
you're pulling content
broadly speaking on the area of
impartiality and the and transposing
those rules and the rules around
elections for example we we would say
that we we recognize there are some
concerns in the market and in the
industry but we would say that
um we are already regulated by ofcom and
by the way that you know Parent PLUS is
notified to off come under the current
rules and we would anticipate that
oftcom would as a kind of well-versed
regulator will address those differences
and find a way to ensure that that
audiences are sufficiently protected
that impartiality is suitably delivered
that during election periods the right
processes are taking place without
instigating too much without instigating
significant business disruption and it's
important that the regulator gets the
balance correct but we have a high
degree in confidence that ofcome will be
able to deliver that okay finally
um can I just come to you Magnus um
earlier on John Nicholson also asked
about a matter I've raised before with
off-com at this committee about
talk TV and it's
um prominence on the electronic
programming guide which comes about as a
result of it purchasing time on the
local TV slot uh um in in many parts of
the country
um would this draft Bill what bill has
drafted do anything to prevent that sort
of activity taking place in future I.E
broadcasters and so-called news channels
that have no actual Public Service
broadcasting remit being able to
purchase places high up on electronic
programming guide by acting as a sort of
succubus on local
TV channels uh no I don't think so
um I mean I think you know in a sense
the whole question of probably get ought
to because well you know I mean I you
know you're you're there on channel
three with your news as a Publishers
broadcast there they are on wherever it
is at all you know
in that sense I think the future of
local TV is a question for government
rather than the question for us to be
okay thank you thanks Kevin Julie thank
you chair
um Mitchell going back to the video on
demand called
um should existing catalogs have to be
compliant with the new code
um well certainly from My Five
perspective
um the vast majority of content has
already been on uh broadcast broadcast
so that we would anticipate that it
would already meet the standards of any
new code
um clearly Services have many thousands
of hours of content um and so what we
would seek that there is either a some
kind of suitable implementation period
to allow catalogs to be
um to give companies time to ensure that
catalogs are do you think it would take
for your catalogs to be checked to be
compliant um it's a good question I
don't know the answer to that and I
can't answer that right now but I would
I would what I would say is that off-com
should consult with industry and find a
suitable reasonable I think it's
completely reasonable could anybody in
your organization answer that or is it
just if your company doesn't know the
answer well I would I would anticipate
so for us specifically so my five most
of the content has already been
broadcast on linear TV and for Paramount
plus we're already notified in the UK to
ofcom under its odps odps codes so I
would imagine for us as a business it
would be a reasonably short period of
time however the same time I recognize
that that we are not there are some
services that are planned that are
currently not regulated in the UK which
this bill intends to bring into scope
and clearly um that must be a
consideration for offcome as well and in
what way could the requirements be
signed programming on Paramount plus be
problematic
um
we we think that there needs to be
consultation with those who use British
sign language in order to assess what
the um their expectations are so let's
give you an example
um on on I was going to talk you through
our business as it were channel five we
have five percent signing that as Our
obligation that's what we deliver
we also have a series of pay TV channels
um which you know the brands Comedy
Central Nickelodeon
um MTV and and for those we hit the
threshold of being required signing but
it's deemed that because the expense is
so great to to put signing on those
channels and it would be a very limited
amount of signing on you know channels
which have relatively low viewing
compared to the PSPs there was a scheme
set up
um I'm gonna get my dates from but just
around a decade ago but with ofcom in
order to instead of putting signing on
those channels we give very significant
amount of money to the British sign
language broadcasting trust which makes
programming in British sign language so
it makes programs that schemes we feel
works very well and we feel
um that there should be some kind of
consultation uh I think that would be a
model to be extended to make this work
if that's what the British sign language
Community wants
I I you know we pose it as a question in
our response rather than saying this is
what is required but clearly that scheme
works very effectively and there may
need to be some flexibility with that
scheme but clearly there needs to be
some consultation and it should be those
users of British sign language also
being consulted as part of this to
explain what they would like to see as
outcomes from this bill
today can I thank all the witnesses for
their time today particularly for your
forbearance at the beginning of this
session where we had a few technical
issues a number of you have mentioned
additional bits of written evidence
which we'd be very grateful to receive
and in the meantime thank you very much
for your time today order order thank
you